buddy i don't want to say but i i've
i've just had people on this couch that
hadn't figured it out yet we're we're
waiting for it you're hearing 20 years
of therapy here yeah you know i mean it
took you a while to figure that out yeah
please
where else did you look before you found
this balance oh please yeah you know i i
put way too much emphasis on work yeah
um what people thought of you
oh well or just whether or not you're
working
yeah what you
know
how am i seen do i have power do i have
control do i have
you know i know better uh if we've did
it my way you know it's all that stuff
the ego the ego has to learn i had
you know i i didn't realize that i had
crap as a kid i thought i was a pretty
happy kid but i
turns out i was a pretty intimidated shy
overwhelmed
disproportionately scared kid who
overcompensated with all kinds of awful
silly behaviors and
and it carried in you know until i was
in my 20s and 30s until i finally went
you know i'm a father and i'm having
these weird feelings and ideas and
things that are the the things you were
talking about the the rolodex of things
you up at night going yeah you want to
think about that for a while you want to
think about that for a while yeah and
you know finally went into therapy and
started to work on what were those
things i i'm not this isn't click bait
you have full control over this no
they're just i mean
i'm curious
you know the easy ones are things where
i will have said things in interviews
that i thought i was just being
entertaining
[Music]
and i was never a comic i didn't even go
into acting thinking i was going to be a
comedic actor and suddenly that's the
world i'm in and in trying to be funny
and i don't i don't
i guess i
now i kind of go well i guess i have a
sense of humor but i never thought of
myself as a funny guy and so in
emulating
comedy and trying to be interesting and
trying to be entertaining and trying to
be amusing i would say things that you
know weren't kind
and weren't right and and and
you know um you see that all the time by
the way and augmenting things that are
partially true but then you you for
entertainment you blow them up and now
they're out there as truth and you go oh
that's not quite how it happened and
you're and you're stuck with that story
and just stuff like that hurting
people's feelings making bad choices
saying i'm gonna be something not being
it say i'm gonna do something not doing
it the thin line between
i run into it all the time i did on set
today i'm i'm stopping myself cause i'm
43 i'm finally learning to stop myself
but there's a thin line the the rush of
going maybe a little too far but it
works and they love it and you love it
and everyone wins now you're addicted to
those moments and then inevitably you're
going to say a little too far a little
too much
and and you just don't know how to cook
and it was all about you know trying to
be
some avatar that i thought was
interesting and you know or worthy
worthy is really more the the issue
because i always
felt like
i shouldn't be there
yeah um
you know people should one of the
i guess a lot of actors go into acting
because they love the spotlight i was
hiding in plain sight yeah i didn't love
being in my skin i didn't i wasn't fond
of myself
so i would
say things to give a different
impression or i would play a part it was
a break so yeah so i could so i'm not
that guy i'm this guy
and
it was all in this sort of
very immature
young immature
attempt to find your own value to be
okay in your own skin
and i didn't start to get there until i
was
late into my
40s i think i'm 62 now so i haven't i
haven't been
you know anywhere close to being oh
you're okay this is a relatively new
you know thing and it it's
it's a lot of experience and a lot of
putting real time and attention
egotistical time and attention into
yourself but
real time you know
going to a therapist and being honest
and and going that was a terrible thing
mistake finding a way to get past it and
going okay
that happened for a reason i'm here now
yeah and and
now i know what what calls people to
that and one of the one of the lovely
gifts it gives
is that i have younger friends who are
going through exactly the same thing
and i can say to somebody who's going
through a tough patch you don't think
much of yourself right now
you're in one of the top five percent of
people in the world you know why because
you give a and you're looking at it
and it's scary and it's dark and you
don't like what you see in the mirror
and you're still looking in the mirror
and you're still working on it that
makes you better than most people not
worse wow it takes it takes guts and
character and it takes caring about
other people
to keep looking in the mirror and not
seeing what you like and go i have to
work on this
wow i have to work on this so
you know
[Music]